pour que votre fête ne débute pas ainsi
il vous faut le bon outil
frédéric notre testeur en résidence et
nadia chroniqueuse 20 ont ouvert
beaucoup de bouteilles afin d'évaluer
différents modèles payer entre 5 et 70
dollars
la qualité première de bons petits
bouchons c'est d'éviter que le bouchon
sebring parce qu'on va pas se ramasser
avec des morceaux glisse une partie du
bouchon qui tombe dans les bras on a
identifié vraiment quatre années donc le
limonadier classique qu'on retrouve
beaucoup dans les restaurants que les
professionnels utilisent
on a un modèle qui est quand même assez
anciens qu'on a baptisé à double levier
et il ya depuis quelques années un type
de modèle qui existe ce qu'on a appelé
rotation le contenu on fait juste
tourner la vrille sans fond en bouche on
est le bouchon lève aussi en même temps
et lui ce merveilleux modèles ici que
j'ai baptisé et tous et levier simple
[Musique]
l'appui simple exige qu'à poignet du
limonadiers ça vraiment plus penché
c'est un petit peu moins confortable
tandis que l'appui double se fait en
deux temps
donc la poignée est bien droite beaucoup
plus confortable donc un premier geste
et une fois que je suis monté assez haut
je passe au deuxième et puis pour tous
les modèles
un des points importants à vérifier
c'est la longueur de lavery cg une
vrille qui est courte il ya peu de
chances que maverick dépasse dans la
bouteille et créent des miettes de liège
ces jeunes vrille qui est longue il ya
plus de chances que avril dépasse
sortent du bouchon et que les miettes de
liège le plastique la profondeur à
laquelle on va faire pénétrer laverie
est plus ou moins importante parce que
déjà le plastique et aucune chance qui
se brise en deux ans nous première
catégorie les limonadiers classique
théo centre au départ et laverie et tout
de suite migrer vers l'extérieur j'ai
quand même un minimum d'expérience puis
je me dis que la personne à la maison
qui oppose souvent des bouteilles de vin
pourrait trouver ce fait pas tout à fait
fluide
quatre modèles à double appui ont bien
performé autant pour le liège que pour
le plastique où il faut appuyer ici avec
leur ça ça se passe bien
ça prend un peu plus de pratiquer ces
algues onomique c'est bien si le produit
est abordable je dirais oui si ça coûte
plus que 10 12 dollars ce serait pas mon
préféré
lavery sans france bien vraiment celui
là j'irai presque pour un 3 3 mai 2011
yin li fort c'est celui qui était le
plus agréable à manoeuvrer
2e catégorie li modèle à double levier
qui sont les plus populaires mais
demande une certaine dextérité
c'est étonnant que ce soit le modèle le
plus répandu chez les non professionnels
parce que ça me prend beaucoup plus de
dextérité de concentration pour être sûr
de bien faire après 1 2 verre on peut
vite perdre le focus et c'est pas
agréable pour les mettre dans la bouche
on est en train de se défaire puis
éventuellement mais il faut terminer
comme ça avec le et lavrilleux sortie
donc vous irez points sur une échelle
dit c'est pas mal un ratage total
rien qui est stable donc ça me donne
l'impression mais quelque chose qui
coûte trop cher et j'ajouterais que ça
vaut prochain donc pas chez moi ou le
lie à genève le liège est en train de
s'effriter les joies des petites miettes
sur le dessus
c'est quand même un peu plus stable que
le précédent mais les brosses sont
encore pas très ergonomique pas agréable
à manoeuvrer et à moins de vouloir tirer
de toutes mes forces et de terminer avec
la bouteille et entre les genoux il faut
encore que j'enfonce laverie davantage
on a un point fort dans cette catégorie
moi j'ai un appui sur la bouteille d'une
meilleure stabilité
on voit que l'inconvénient de cette
catégorie là c'est de réussir à bien
placer la vraie absolument et d'avoir
une stabilité mais de celui là on a
vraiment plus de stabilité
les deux bras sont plus ergonomique pour
besoin de glisser des fois non et on n'a
toujours pas le terril le bout du
bouchon à dalle dans la catégorie c
l'eau mais là c'est un gagnant bien
conception quand même c'est assez
esthétique aussi
dans la catégorie à rotation continue
les 3 ouvre bouteille ont le même de
tous la vérité passe encore mais bon
c'est la conception même de l'objet des
modèles qui offre par contre un certain
avantage
je peux penser à certaines personnes
dans ma famille qui ont des problèmes
d'arthrite d'arthrose celui-là cela neuf
vraiment comme un charme
finalement les plus chères du lot assez
bien la poignée et et ergonomique
on n'a pas dépassé la longueur du
bouchon on a encore un demi tour deux
vrilles et pour extraire le bouchon ça
se fait en un charme
aion efforts à fournir quand m ça sent
taiwan dextérité fine mais plus de
blancs sur les quinze modèles les plus
performants ont été les limonadiers à
double appui et en particulier le choo
qui bonne nouvelle est de loin le moins
cher ça vaut la peine de se donner le
temps de développer l'habilité pour
manipuler le petit ça semble être un peu
plus intimidant parce que c'est le
modèle qui est utilisé par les
professionnels mais il est souvent moins
coûteux beaucoup plus polyvalent va vous
permettre d'ouvrir des bouteilles avec
des bouchons plastiques avec des
bouchons de liège aggloméré avec des
bouchons de liège conventionnelle et si
vous tenez à acheter un modèle à double
levier c'est le oxo qui a le mieux
performé
[Musique]